[Musique]
dans les forêts d'amérique du nord
un jamal prépare son panache chez des
cervidés la coiffure est essentiel des
mal et investissent beaucoup d'énergie
grâce à leurs bois il espère vaincre
leurs rivaux et séduire les femelles
une fois le rude terminée la majorité
des cervidés perd sa parure mais le
wapiti sens du lot il conserve sa
couronne beaucoup plus longtemps que les
autres et certains mâles sont des
coiffes et plusieurs semaines après leur
procurant pourquoi des biologistes de
l'université du montana ou voulu
comprendre pendant 13 ans ils ont suivi
les wapitis du parc de yellowstone
pour eux la question est épineuse
les bois viennent avec plusieurs
inconvénients
d'abord ils sont lourds environ 5% du
poids de la bête ces immenses structures
demandent beaucoup d'énergie à l'animal
les bois sont recouverts d'un duvet qui
transporte sans et nutriments vers le
panache le mâle consacre une partie de
son alimentation pour les maintenir en
place et ce aux dépens de sa santé
lorsque le niveau de testostérone du mal
des sens le duvet disparaît les bois
durs 6 étant finalement plus les boîtes
honte au plus l'animal dispose de temps
pour refaire sa coiffure
le mâle bénéficie alors de plus grands
bois l'automne suivant
pour les scientifiques la clé du mystère
se trouveraient dans la prédation
si des wapitis mal pour des rivaux ils
ont aussi des prédateurs parmi eux les
redoutables meute de loups d'oeil à
l'hosto
[Musique]
les biologistes ont constaté que les
mâles dans les boîtes plutôt sont plus
souvent la cible des attaques de seynod
ça suggère que pour le wapiti les bois
sont de grands ultime d'un timide à sion
il leur serait encore plus utile
espèce il ne peut compter contrairement
à l'orignal sur sa masse corporelle pour
intimider à prédateurs ou à l'agilité
opéré au cerf de virginie
grâce à sa petite taille c'est moi
deviennent ses principaux outils de
défense
les chercheurs du montana ont ainsi mis
en lumière la deuxième fonction de moi
des wapitis s'ils sont avant tout une
arme de séduction et de compétition
sexuelle
ils sont aussi un outil de dissuasion
les wapitis mal et potec donc leur santé
pour assurer leur sécurité
[Musique]